[Music]
Chad GPT is passing the test required
for medical licenses and business
degrees oh perfect so let's hop on chat
gbt right now Chad gbt how do I do open
heart surgery yeah please
I think that I want to start trying to
use this legitimately in YouTube somehow
like even just generating ideas like
just training it on like
like saving all the videos that I find
interesting training it on the titles
and then having it spit me out ideas for
my next video something that's actually
productive you know yeah I want to use
it more like a crawler I'd love it to go
out and summarize a a ton of varying
opinions on things yeah I mean that's
definitely going to be
uh the wave in the next couple years I
think summarize the perfect reviews on
The Dark Knight
it was mid
it was mid according to the TMG podcast
The Dark Knight received widespread
critical Acclaim upon its release in
2008.
um overall the film is considered a
Triumph here let's do this copy and
paste that relationship advice and be
like what should he do
oh
let's read this first
I 22 female yeah I think my brother 25
male unknowingly subscribed to my only
fans
not sure what I want from this maybe
advice reassurance
I started in only fans a year or so ago
I was struggling with bills on and on
um I'll do anything not to live at the
home I have it's toxic religious no
privacy Etc
I decided to do one of those faceless
only fans pages so I never show my full
face
usually cropped her with covet style
face mask I wear bright colored wigs and
different eye makeup live in a smaller
town so didn't want this getting around
it was slow at first but after a bit I
was able to get a decent sized following
and make just enough income to pay rent
slash bills monthly
scroll down
recently though I started getting
requests from a person whose location
was my nearby City didn't think much of
it at first thought it could be anyone
we started requesting custom videos
first just like generic stuff slash
positions they became more personal he
pays a lot for it too
uh it's like the reason why I don't need
to live at home is because of oh God
the thing is a personal request you kind
of reveal parts of him like his job how
old he is and most recently he wanted me
to say his name oh
didn't think much of it because it's a
generic name but maybe hesitate because
of the same name as my brother that and
the similar ages and job being the same
field made me question uh it at first uh
but since then I just told myself it was
all chance and since my brother goes by
a nickname and the money was paying so
well I ignored my suspicions and did a
few videos
the most recent request though is what
made my gut and heart sink he requested
a video uh this time but instead of
using the previous name he wanted me to
use a new name the nickname he goes by
oh I mean this is obviously your brother
uh I don't know if he has an idea it's
me
don't know how because I've been hiding
everything that can be tied to me uh or
if he feels just more comfortable with
sharing that personal information to a
random
the nickname is kind of common for his
name but unique enough for him like 70
sure it's him I mean you got to be more
than 70 sure like I know uh
I don't know what to do I'm feelings
[__] no matter what I do even
horrendous
all right so let's go to chat GPT ask it
if it understands what only fans is it
definitely knows what only fans is but
I'm just curious like that's another
thing I've been curious about with Chad
gbt is like conversing with it like a
person yeah
okay now say okay now do you know what
the relationship advice subreddit is all
about no I was going to say why don't we
put it like we're her
okay like in this chat where you say I
currently run and only fans and I
believe my brother has unknowingly oh no
yeah you can just copy and paste bombs
away
it sounds content very difficult and
uncomfortable situation the fact that
you're questioning whether the person
making requests for custom videos is
your brother is understandably causing
you a lot of stress and anxiety it's
important to remember that your safety
and well-being are the most important
things and you should do what feels best
for you if you suspect that the person
making the request maybe your brother or
maybe best to stop responding to his
requests and potentially even
discontinue your only fans account
altogether
this could be a different difficult
decision especially if the income from
the account has been helping you
financially but your mental and
emotional well-being is crucial
interesting how you're saying that like
how would the have how would the brother
have found this account if it's a random
small account like
how did
how does that even happen
I want does I wonder if only fans does
like Geo type stuff
no I don't think it does that would be
you can't like search yeah yeah that
wouldn't make sense if you knew like the
location of the people you were
subscribed to
uh maybe not I I guess I wasn't thinking
so specific but like you know state
local but yeah even then that's kind of
a risk
and and additionally it's like how would
you not recognize
like you wouldn't need to see your
sister's face I feel like to recognize
her hair
well she's wearing wigs
oh yeah
but
I feel there are other just nuanced
things about a sibling or a family
member that you would recognize yeah
that's what I'm saying I feel I feel
that even
when you have siblings or cousins or
whatever you you even notice
you notice things about them in other
people you know where you meet someone
you might go like oh
they you know they just look like this
person just looks like my cousin or they
you know what I mean like or I met this
person they act like this person I know
so I I feel that there's no way
the brother doesn't know I that's what
I'm saying which is [__] disgusting
yeah dude
it sounds like a TLC show honestly
I 21 male think my mom 43 female wants
to bone this guy who's my roommate on
this TV yeah this is like the next TLC
show it's like my my sister's only Fan's
life or something oh dude don't give
them ideas they're already they're an
only fans model and I like it
mommy makeout day
this is just uh what's his face you know
I banged my sister whoever did that
YouTube prank oh my God what was that
guy's name a prank invasion there's that
guy there's that other Niche guy like
who had his girlfriend he's like walking
in on my sister masturbating
do you remember prank Invasion though
remember of course yeah he kissed his
sister right or his supposed sister yeah
it was a fake sister I thought what the
[__] is he up to nowadays I'm about to
look it up right please division Luke
can you scroll down I just want to see
like who left the comment on this and
what they said yeah I mean it seems like
this is probably fake because what
It's gotta be fake dude
uh this dude I guess just disappeared
off the map
hasn't done anything
I don't know he's on sunnyv2 so that
leads me to believe you don't really
have [__] going on I see